Over the last few days, democratic presidential
candidate Pete Buddha judge was involved in
some really strange exchanges and most of
them have to do with money in politics, campaign
finance, uh, transparency and it does not
look good for mayor Pete.
The first one is at a press conference before
or after an event and he's asked about why
won't you open up fundraisers to the press?
He's very Curt and he says he doesn't have
a timeline for when he's going to consider
doing that.
He's then asked to follow up.
Well, you're the candidate, can't you just
tell your campaign to open them up to the
press?
And mayor Pete says, yes, but there are considerations.
And then he's asked as another followup, what
are the considerations?
And he says, I'm not going to tell you.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
Earlier today you said you were open to having
a conversation about opening or fundraisers.
And that's a question that reporters have
been asking me for months now.
So I'm wondering when do you expect to be,
to actually have that conversation and give
like stance on that as, as the candidate Kevin
just directed.
Yes.
And what happens with that?
And I'm thinking about it, last question,
can you give us an example of those considerations?
No, thank you.
Thank you.
Is this a strategy of some kind because it
comes off looking absolutely terrible.
Doing close to the press events I don't actually
think is problematic in principle.
It's actually a good thing for elected officials
and candidates to be able to talk to voters
privately without the press there.
I think that that's generally speaking a good
thing, uh, but in some instances, but when
it's big money fundraisers and there's already
slipperiness coming from Pete about campaign
finance and then this is how he answers the
questions.
It doesn't look good.
Here's another video.
We're a student activist named Greg Chung
asks, P Buddha judge, when we talk about getting
money out of politics, shouldn't that include
not taking money from million from billionaires
and doing closed-door fundraisers?
And Pete just says, no, that's not what my
getting money out of politics should include.
I know the audio is not great on this one.
The video is subtitled.
Apologies for people who are just listening.
I know that it may be hard to understand everything
that's said.
[inaudible]
I saw comments about this saying, Oh, this
is totally tone deaf.
It's not that it's tone deaf, it's that this
is Pete Buddha judge telling us what he really
believes.
He doesn't want to stop billionaire donations
or private fundraisers because he's a centrist
status quo guy.
Period.
The bar for transparency, particularly on
this issue of money and politics has definitely
changed in the last few years with more and
more candidates saying they won't accept corporate
PAC money or uh, money from corporations at
all or whatever.
Pete, Buddha, judge and Joe Biden are just
behind on this.
They are completely out of touch with what
is expected now on the progressive left, what
I do think is good is that in the same way
that Joe Biden isn't pretending to be a super
progressive, he's running as a centrist and
he is a centrist Pete.
Buddha judge is doing the same thing, although
to a lesser degree, yes, Pete is being slippery
on Medicare for all with this Medicare for
all who want it thing, but on lots of these
issues.
I'm glad that Biden is just telling it to
us like it is and Pete is telling it to us
like it is in their policy.
I disagree with them.
I am well to their left, but one of the things
that's really good is with some candidates
you get this sense that they're not really
telling us what they actually believe.
This was asserted about Hillary Clinton in
2016 that everything was just what she thought
would sound best at the time.
This has been asserted with other candidates
as well with mayor Pete and Joe Biden, they
seem to be centrists.
Their policies are Centrus policies.
They are telling us that in public, they're
not hiding behind it.
And I like it because it makes it much easier
for me to figure out.
Both of these guys are well to my right.
They are not the people that I would consider
supporting in a primary.
He's being upfront.
It's fine for him to say this, but we need
to do away with the false notion that Buddha
judges any kind of progressive period and
he's making that a very easy notion to do
away with every time he says something like
this.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Increasingly a very popular place to watch
our videos.
And while you're there,
follow me at David dot. [inaudible].
We'll take a quick break and do backwards
so much more right after this